first of all welcome back and it's so
exciting to see so many familiar faces
many of you don't look different at all
in the last five years so you look
fantastic let me just say that I also
wanted to give you kind of a road map of
what we're going to do I'm going to talk
a little bit about why I'm happy to be
here right now Friday night with you
guys without alcohol but you know I know
it's outside and I'm luring you so I'm
going to try and make sure that this is
sort of spiced up then I'm going to talk
a little bit about the power of story in
two regards the first is as an asset
strategically for business and raise
your hands if you founded your own
company or are working sort of at your
own company in some way shape or form so
that's like I don't know 25 percent of
the people and how many of you have been
at a company that you that you started
with right when you finished the GSB
raise your hands it's about four to 20
percent so I'm going to be asking both
of you groups of people a set of
questions about sort of thinking about
story as a strategic asset then I'm
going to turn to this idea of story as
life this idea that story maybe better
than anything else in our life both
captures meaning and creates meaning so
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about what I hope you do on Monday so
first of all before I dive in I wanted
to lay out a framework some recent
research that I've done with step Kivar
and cassimy gildner and this is based
off of a data set called we feel fine
which septum bar and Jonathan Harris
pulled together and the way to read this
simple slide is which is by the way and
essentially a summary of 10,000 data
over 10,000 data points over three years
I'm over across cultures and it's blog
based data where Sepp and Jonathan
scrape the blogosphere for all mentions
of I feel and I am feeling and then they
come co-vary what people are feeling and
what they're saying doing feeling etc
when they're talking about certain
emotions because blog based data has
demographics associated with it you can
then start to better understand sort of
the emotional lexicon of our lives so
the way to read this slide is we start
out simple this is your 11 to 14 year
old son daughter nephew niece sibling
who when you say you know how are you
feeling they say how was your day
what you do today exactly you know them
you have them in your life but soon we
fill up with angst so this is the 15 to
18 year old who feels a great deal of
angst when they do feel happy it's
equated with excitement
quite literally happiness and excitement
co-vary in a very significant way and
it's not that they feel excited all the
time or angsty all the time it's that
the meaning of happiness the definition
of happiness is associated with
excitement until we leave those feelings
behind and then start to feel more sort
of unknown confined alone in 1920-21 you
start to feel not well understood
oftentimes and then we started to feel
like we could conquer the world at 22 to
26 now we start to feel that we actually
have a goal and that we know what we're
doing the meaning of happiness starts to
equate with feeling proud or satisfied
or still excited before gradually
trading ambitious abyssion for a balance
so at 30 we start to say we're
imbalanced we forgot to have kids I
stopped working out oops and so the
feeling of happiness is equated with
feeling aligned again developing an
appreciation for our physical bodies at
35 they've gone downhill in a very
systematic way surprisingly we wake up
and were like wow how did that happen
and our children an evolving sense of
connectedness for which we feel grateful
happy calm and then blessed and as some
of you know with this data it's not that
you die at 55 it's that there's just not
the rich emotional lexicon and I also
actually and this is actually 12 million
data points not 10,000 so this is 12
million data points worldwide so it's a
very very large data set to help unpack
the emotional lexicon of our lives so
what we've done with this was we started
to say if this is the story of our lives
and if this is in fact the story of the
lives of our customers so even if you've
captured a strong value for your
customer this research would suggest
that the the value proposition is going
to shift in pretty systematic ways every
5 or 10 years and it's the story of our
employees so even if again your employee
set is incredibly happy this research
would suggest and in five or ten years
they're going to be shifting again so
the way to think about this and it's not
just across your life this is sort of
the story of a project or even a day you
get here for the Alumni weekend and you
have again you know sort of the story
that's unfolding and I'd be really
curious invite anyone to actually tell
me at the end of this reunion weekend
just email me jo Kerr at Stanford what
was the story of the weekend what's the
story that you actually are going to
tell your friends family or whatever
about this weekend you're not going to
say like I went on Friday and I thought
Jennifer and then I went on Saturday and
I saw my friends you're not going to
you're not going to do that you're going
to tell a story and that's the way
you're going to remember this experience
so you start out with discovery you know
as we are at this moment where you don't
really know your goals you don't know
exactly what's going to happen and the
meaning of happiness again is about
excitement then you move to pursuit so
you might know your goals you want to
try and talk to a few people or be able
to connect it and there the feeling is
like I'm feeling like I'm winning or I'm
conquering the world or at least I know
what I'm doing and then you move to
balance and you say you know how can i
line my
my family my work my health and then you
move to impact where you wake up and you
say you know man I've been so so focused
or focused on my family but really what
is my impact in the world and what is
the pro-social benefit that I want to be
able to create where the meaning of
happiness is much more associated with
feeling significant and then you move to
savoring where instead of being more
forward-looking you're more present
oriented and the meaning of happiness is
associated with feeling content in the
here and now and how many of you know
individuals that and again it's not just
over your life there's some individuals
that just feel very content and savoring
even if they're 18 and conversely
there's 55 year olds who are excited all
of the time and in fact we have research
to show that if we give 18 year olds the
task to breathe deeply focused on the
present like pretend you guys do in fact
do it all now breathe deeply focus on
the present you guys bring normal okay
okay keep it up for the whole talk I
it's incredibly hard to do but I can't
begin to tell you the physiological
benefit that it will actually give you
so I challenge you to do that and then
these 18 year olds breathe normally and
we come back and we ask them two very
different questions you know what is the
meaning of happiness and you guys define
it as excitement there's one person
listening I love you fantastic and then
you guys after breathing deeply focused
on the present and feeling very
connected actually define happiness as
contentment like a 55 year old would so
for very you know sort of with five
minutes of deep breathing focused on the
present at in a more meditative state
you can actually change your mindset in
fact we gave you guys choices like do
you want a peppermint refreshing tea or
and you are more likely to pick the
peppermint refreshing team because often
we make choices based on our definition
of happiness or how to optimize whereas
you're much more likely to choose a tea
that's very peaceful and calming my
chamomile
so the point here being that our meaning
of happiness changes over the life
course over a project and even within
the day as something as small as five
minutes now this research was really
exciting for me and I'll start to
explain why the first is that it shows
that in even though most people believe
that happiness is either one thing or in
fact it's individuals so all whatever
300 people here have a unique definition
of happiness this research suggests that
happiness and its meaning changes in
very systematic ways all the way from
excitement to essentially contentment
and the second insight is that what
people are valuing which is and what
they're searching for is really
different so what we find is at 8:18
we're often valuing this notion of I
just want to feel happy and for me
that's excitement and at age thirty
forty fifty you're starting to feel like
I just want to feel like I mean
in my life that feeling of fulfillment
that feeling of joy and contentment and
so what people are optimizing for making
choices based on is a really different
utility function now these two things
happiness versus meaning are often
equated in fact forty percent of the
forty fifty percent of the variance in
these two constructs are both positive
so it's hard to kind of unpack them but
we've done that to some degree and if
anyone's interested just kind of Google
happiness versus meaning and you can
dive into the data but I wanted to
summarize the differences between these
two very positive constructs because it
has a lot to do with my premise which is
I hope you start leading lives that are
filled with stories to a much greater
degree than maybe you are so far so the
first difference between sort of chasing
happiness or living a life based on this
idea of valuing or searching for
happiness versus meaning is that
happiness feels good so if you ask
people like listen how happy are you and
what degree do you feel like you have a
meaningful life and then you know people
obviously have you know different
ratings on a 1.7 scale you can start to
partial out the positive covariance and
those two things and we can start to
peel apart those individuals who feel
very happy but don't feel like they have
a lot of meaning and individuals that
feel like I've a lot of meaning but not
necessarily happy so in that way we can
start to see that happiness is about
really feeling good and meaningfulness
does too but not always so there's a lot
of low points anxiety fear etc wrapped
up and feeling sort of meaning there's a
lot of ups there's a lot of downs it's
sort of a roller coaster so if you think
about it from a story structure
perspective it's not winning winning
winning winning it's winning losing
winning trying winning there's an arc to
the life of meaning the second is that
happiness is more focused on yourself
people that claim to be very happy but
not a lot of meaning are very self rate
themselves as been self focused and more
egocentric the individuals that say that
they have a lot of meaning that they may
are less happy are very anchored on
others giving to others feeling
connected to others and the third and
last just difference is that happiness
is about how you feel now and
meaningfulness is about the past the
present in the future it's much more
lasting so these are three of maybe the
more important differences between
meaning but it's really hard to sort of
ask yourself well I'm going to go out
and have a meaningful day or where's
meaning found and the contention would
be that meaning is is both captured and
created in all a second person I love
awesome okay you saw where I was going
with this so stories all right so what
is this story three sort of ways to
define it it's marked by ups and downs
and sort of highs and lows it's a
narrative with a beginning and the
middle and an end and again it's not
just winning winning winning there's no
tension there there's no evolution it's
actually an arc so if you start to think
about James Bond films right Wow what
happened I don't know he gets the girl
the arc is very clear and it's repeated
again and again and again or Jurassic
Park nothing going on t-rex and then go
on big t-rex nothing really really big
t-rex so it's not a sophisticated arc
but it's still an art or Casablanca
where there's micro or mini sort of
stories that have arcs that kind of echo
the overall story arc the second thing
that pulls apart story from just a list
of facts or features or to-do list is
that it's it's typically human centered
there's a protagonist and there's
characters and there's the the mix
between both of them many of you know
the six word story written by Ernest
Hemingway who said baby shoes for sale
never worn and we don't know if that's
you know a young couple who couldn't
have a baby or the baby didn't make it
but we do know something about that
story and neurologically what's
happening when you share a story versus
just say there was a young couple and
they couldn't have a baby is that the
person listening to the story is making
the inference about the story and when
people make the inference about the
story it stays in their mind because
it's being processed by both hemispheres
versus what I just share something to
you where you don't have to make the
inference because I'm telling it to you
you don't have to process that
information nearly as deeply so it's
giving people two plus two and they are
inferring the four instead of just
giving them four so how many of you have
been in one of my classes oh my god like
40% alright so you probably have done
this but it's it's really fun to do it a
second time so you're you're gonna so I
make my students always share six-word
stories about their life and here's a
couple more recent ones that not quite
aspiring to be quite tonight he parks
tomorrow i pine married the wrong girl
fixed it
and getting old ringtones pissed me off
so I am going to I'm going to have you
write of course a six word store you can
put it in your iPhone or your cell phone
or I encourage you to take out a piece
of paper if you can and I'm gonna have
you write a six word story about your
Stanford experience so whenever you are
here what was the story of your life
when you were here and I'm going to have
you share someone give you 30 seconds to
write it and remember you don't like
think of a change right remember
thinking how you changed maybe it's a
good little tip encourage you to make it
funny if you have a sense of humor and
if you don't still make it funny and
you're going to share it with the two or
three people next to you so you have 30
seconds go ahead write it or think
okay finishing up all right you're going
to grab the two or three people next to
you and you are going to share your six
word store and you have one minute to
complete all of it alright ready set go
all right
alright coming back
all right I want it I want to see if any
of you want to nominate what are the
people you just talked to that had an
epic story raise your hand raise your
hand I want a couple volunteers who had
a great story
all right there is one there you're
going to come up to the podium can guy
next to the gal who's pointing
vigorously all right
that guy second third and fourth and
fifth okay so we have five and I awesome
you're going to come up to the
microphone because I guess we're live
streamed so
Bangladesh is going to love your story
okay all right say your name and then
your six word story Gregg lamps and it's
the best hundred thousand dollar dating
service
what deal what ideal the best $100,000
dating service
go ahead hi I'm Stephanie Stephanie do I
belong here yes
Wow Oh sweeter a little bit sweeter but
yeah these are a little hard to follow a
Betsey Parker met great people met
myself finally Oh she also is very
efficient with words so that's five
words you got an extra word also DDA old
change except for the accent all right I
think last one is there one more okay
Adrian Lee wrong girl wrong job right
school Oh
um all right so the last thing I want to
leave you with is moving forward into
this weekend really again an open
invitation please send me your six-word
stories of what happened what you hope
happens this weekend and then also what
did in the last the last component of
story is that it lasts over time from a
neurological angle as well as something
that does last actually over time so let
me talk a little bit about let's see if
the volumes on the sciences story once
upon a time information is scarce so we
made decisions based on the advice of
experts using them as North Stars for
instance
now thanks to the internet we can
ourselves try and find our own answers
to questions that plague us and find
information to make informed decisions
but instead of funny clear answers we
often find noise we're living in a world
where we have too much information and
because of that were even more
susceptible to great story it's what
helps us decide what to believe in
stories are important because they're
meaningful and they're meaningful
because they're memorable impactful and
they personally connect first let's talk
about memorability Eugene O'Kelly was a
CEO of a consulting company he started
having headaches he was referred to a
top neurosurgeon in New York where he
was diagnosed a late stage brain cancer
and he was given three months to live he
started talking to his wife how does he
want to spend those hundred days he was
purposeful about who he spent time with
and what stories to share with them he
also thought hard about what would be
remembered in those last 100 days Tina's
wife would live each day with a focus on
finding perfect moments where time
expands and we noise is separated from
signal all that exists is that single
moment and he found in those perfect
moments those were the most memorable
stories that defined his life in one
study researchers asked students to make
a one-minute persuasive pitch to other
members in the class and on average
typicals didn't use 2.5 statistics in
their pitch only one in ten told a story
10 minutes later the researcher asked
everyone to pull out a sheet of paper
and write down every single idea they
remember only 5% remember any statistic
63% of the students remember the story
stories are memorable in a way that
statistics aren't now let me talk about
impact research shows that individuals
are more likely to buy from a person or
an organization whose story they believe
in and which resonates with them in one
study Deb's small at the University of
Pennsylvania and her colleagues wanted
to determine how to best raise money for
Save the Children a charity focused on
the well-being of children work
we created two versions of a marketing
pamphlet the first version featured
statistics about the magnitude of
problems facing children in Africa the
second version also featured those
statistics but in addition provided
information about Rokia a seven-year-old
girl from Mali who faced the threat of
severe hunger the subjects were given
five dollars as compensation for the
study and before leaving the researchers
asked if they wanted to donate any money
to the cause the individuals in the
story condition gave nearly twice as
much money as those in the statistics
condition we used to think it was our
rational brain that makes decisions now
we know it's emotion driving decisions
and we rationalize the decision
afterwards finally I want to talk about
personal connection research shows that
if we present statistics to an audience
a certain part of the brain called the
Broca's and Wernicke's area gets
activated so the language processing
part of the brain is activated and we
can understand but not feel when the
story is shared the audience feels the
story our whole brain is activated and
meaning is extracted the meaning of the
story comes from the personal connection
the audience feels when they're
listening to the story and when a story
is well told they're able to feel
connected not just to the story but to
the storyteller when most of us think of
advocating for ideas we go to statistics
we go to convincing arguments facts and
figures but studies show that if we
share a story people are more likely to
remember the message
be persuaded by it feel personally
connected to it and when data and
stories are used together audiences are
moved both intellectually and
emotionally for lasting effect you need
to persuade the rational brain but also
resonate with emotional brain recent
behavioral research has shown why
stories are so powerful it's because
they're meaningful those who tell the
best stories will become the best
leaders if we consider the simple
question what is the story or why am I
doing this we may find we make very
different choices at how we spend our
time isabel allende once wrote silence
before being born so it's after death
life is nothing but noise between those
two unfathomable silences but there is
no and there is noise and how do we
reduce the noise story pretty awesome
I'm just joking so story is a set let me
just go through the three types of
qualities that companies that harness or
harness story well do they tend to
harness story and in a way that really
design story without the anticip amputee
and purpose so first designed for
authenticity and when you share a story
for CEO you're starting a company you're
you're trying to recruit retain sell you
need to feel authentic research by Nala
neon body shows that people can tell
within milliseconds and meeting you
whether they trust you like you're
whether you're authentic and that type
of science applies when you're
especially sharing stories and both
customers and employees need to believe
your story and be inspired by it and
what what's happening right now in the
world is that brands and organizations
and companies often feel manufactured
but people don't so one of the reasons
stories become this kind of bigger thing
or this notion of people as brands has
become a bigger thing is partly because
of that deep desire to have authenticity
and trust in our relationships hi i'm
mike founder of dollarshaveclub.com what
is dollarshaveclub.com well for $1 a
month we sent high-quality razors right
to your door yeah a dollar are the
blades any good
no our blades are great
each razor has stainless steel blades
and aloe vera lubricating strip and a
pivot head it's so gentle a toddler
could use it and do you like spending
twenty dollars a month on brand-name
razors nineteen go to Roger Federer I'm
good at tennis
do you think your razor needs a
vibrating handle a flashlight a back
scratcher and ten blades your
handsome-ass grandfather had one blade
and polio
looking good pop up stop paying for
shave take you don't need and stop
forgetting to buy your blades every
month Alejandro and I are going to ship
them right to you we're not just selling
razors we're also making new jobs
Alejandra what were you doing last month
not working what are you doing now
waking I'm no Vanderbilt but this train
makes hay
so stop forgetting to buy your blades
every month and start deciding where
you're gonna stack all those dollar
bills I'm saving you
we are dollarshaveclub.com and the party
is on
so I'll come and see you my favorite
part is Alejandra she just looks so
embarrassed there's a lot of companies
that are here in the room right now
raise your hand if you're from
Manchester United he might like a good
Australian be drinking alcohol already
so I'm not sure but are in English right
anyway
I I'm not a big sports guy but we're
word on the street is that Manchester
United people really are authentically
sports people a second incredibly
authentic brand is Phil's right how many
of you drink Phil's so the authenticity
that comes with the debrief des and
everything about Phil's just oozes
authenticity the second thing that
strong brands that that harness story
well do they design for empathy so it's
not all about them they know that brands
too often try to be the hero of their
story but more often than not customers
are the hero and that has gone into
Twitter who's done a really good job at
least of documenting some of the stories
of ordinary people harnessing Twitter or
Facebook or YouTube in ways that that
make those platforms clear in terms of
its value and some of you have already
enjoyed this but Google which is really
struggled from a marketing perspective
because they won't talk about themselves
and if you hire a whole bunch of smart
people and they just actually make great
product the product should sell so when
Google Chrome did not get adopted it was
not being used to the degree that Google
thought they should they had a real
problem because if they don't believe in
marketing how are they going to get
adoption and their answer to that
question was story
you
you're using for each day
you
so that single ad which then led to
Super Bowl ads and whatnot
was in fact the reason why Google Chrome
started getting adopted and it wasn't
just a focus on google chrome it was
really a focus on Daniel Lee this idea
of deep empathy being a way of telling
the story where Google Chrome is just
enabling Daniel Lee to be a great dad
and in fact makes us all want to go have
kids again because we forgot to do
everything that Daniel Lee did damn
could have more kids
so kitch it I think it's done a really
good job around designing around empathy
and really understanding what that user
wants I think also master class has done
a really remarkable job by David Raji a
to say you know we want to democratize
learning and the ability to actually
create skills around story writing
tennis and we're going to do it in
affordable ways and I think also Sequoia
creative they've done a really good job
from a venture perspective a better
understanding not just their CEOs but
the the users of the CEOs product and
unlocking that story
third and last design for purpose this
notion that Tom's and Warby Parker and
you know body shop or Ben and Jerry's
all of these companies that have in
their core with the larger mission or
the larger inspired mission is is
starting but slowly I think especially
here at Stanford to get baked in in a
deeper way and business models and you
see people like Ben Horowitz say things
like the company story is the company
strategy the story must explain why you
exist why we're doing this why does the
problem need to be solved why should
join the company why should you invest
in it why should you buy a product from
it so all of these things that the story
is not well told if it doesn't come
across the answers these questions will
be no the thing that's important here is
that people want to be valued members of
a winning team on an inspired
and if you get any one of these words
wrong that's when you lose momentum
productivity performance and maybe the
most important word or two in the
sentence is the inspired mission to what
degree do you feel connected to
something bigger something bigger that
your team is enabling your company is
enabling and you're feeling connected to
the world because as the meaning of
happiness shifts in the systemic waves
and you move from feeling excitement to
wanting money and status to wanting some
element of balance you will need that
desire for impact and significance I
think mantra is really done a remarkable
job if you dive into their website and
you understand their business model
they've done purpose in a really clever
and authentic way I think levo league
has done it as well as a mere boat
lastly I wanted to mention I think
stories are important not just as an
asset for companies and leaders but also
in life so some of you guys know that I
have three kids and they're now 14 14
and 10 and and story as a scientist
you're trained to disregard story
literally told to someone shares with
you a story you will not pay attention
to it certainly you want to make a
decision based off of it so um so it's
been really an actually interesting last
five years where our story was shared as
me and it fundamentally changed my life
because I always wanted to be an
oncologist and and and there was a time
where I would you know sort of try and
train in terms of medicine and realized
I'm not going to be the mom I want to be
I'm going to end up being you know a
professor and the reason I chose to be a
professor was because I really wanted to
be this great mom and also a great wife
and a great friend to my family and so
that was the that was really the impetus
to be a marketing professor but I have
to tell you a secret just among the
whatever 300 plus live stream of us I
don't even like marketing so I might not
even like business so
oh I'm finding myself as a marketing
professor in the business school partly
because my dad raised your hand done yep
there you go say hi to everyone hi
everyone um partly because my dad was
such a phenomenal father and I saw my
father who was a professor just be
remarkable and he raised us with stories
he would take us on special days where
my two sisters and I would get to go out
with my father and he would take us
basically to where he wanted to go and
we would never want to go but he called
it a special day
and so therefore we were so excited and
when they would take pictures and and
then and then we would be able to
remember it I would anticipate it as
special we'd remember it as special and
even if we had a horrible time at the
Cal game or whatever it was we didn't
remember we didn't anticipate to
remember it and and that way of living
that way of raising us as kids based on
story became incredibly incredibly
important to me such that I made a
career decision to be a professor and
hopefully be that parent and partner
that I had seen in my family and so that
was kind of the context of living story
as a way of living certainly infiltrated
you know the way I was brought up and
its impacted the way you know we've
raised our kids and I wanted to share
two anecdotes with you the first is the
way to get into marriage therapy but the
way my husband and I actually relate is
fundamentally different because of a
story shared with me to give you a
little bit of background on my husband
Andy Smith who's a venture capitalist at
the time maybe five or six years ago or
a little bit more he was running global
brands at Dolby and and was you know
really enamored with technology IOT
social media
etc I thought social media was complete
crap and so skeptical that we would
really argue oh and at the dinner on the
dinner table and you know even in front
of our kids about you know what you do
today oh I created a social media
strategy for Dolby and I'd say that
seems like a waste of time
you're a business-to-business brandon he
would say you're a marketing professor
at Stanford and you've never been on
Facebook that's doesn't seem smart and
so whenever we disagree I usually run a
study to see if I'm right so I asked I
asked 100 people representative of the
United States what they thought of a
social media and about 50% of them said
very positive words and the other 50 or
so percent of them again said a lot of
negative words which at least made me
feel vindicated so you know in this
belief that social media was completely
destroying destroying the world at that
time and and remember like I'm
heads-down publishing my papers
analyzing big data sets you know and and
sort of disagreeing with Andy on a few
things
but I was teaching this creativity and
innovation class and one of my students
Robert Chatwin who some of you might
know shared with me a story at the end
of the class of how the class impacted
him and he shared this story of Samira's
best friend here a Stanford undergrad
who went off and created his own company
just like 20% of you and got married
fell in love with Reena and was
diagnosed with the leukemia when they
were traveling in India and he was
shocked called Robert and Robert was
shocked and asked their friendship their
friend network what they should be doing
and they learned that another friend of
theirs Vinay here in Fremont was also
recently diagnosed with leukemia and
many of you know this data but I'll just
share it with you in silence
so Robert wrote a story about Sameer and
that story about Sameer and those first
two paragraphs is so clear that if
anyone got this email they felt like
they knew him you're so often asked to
do things but without a story you're not
compelled to read or act and then the
clear call-to-action please get
registered spread the word and learn
more come to these websites and they
took that simple story with a call to
action and they harness social media and
and and Robert reversed the rules he did
things in very unexpected ways he didn't
just build out the story and put it on
the website and share it via social
media channels they actually created two
organizations team Vinay and team Sameer
and use Google Docs and other tools to
be able to communicate these instant
websites were also clear calls to action
where if you double clicked on any of
the links up came a essentially a
dragonfly type of model where any of
these links were live off of the website
so if you were here at Stanford and you
wanted to run a corporate drive up would
come a bone marrows drive to work a
dummy's guide and all of these links are
live so if you double-click the text in
red up comes a letter dear Garth I want
to run a bone marrow drive here this
Friday on alumni weekend this is what we
need to do cut pay send and even a thank
you letter we ran a drive last Friday we
got to know people in thank you very
much this is what we need to do next cut
pay send so that social change in a box
made that story ignite in very
significant ways and many of you know of
people acted they they created Facebook
ads and YouTube videos and shared it on
their own social media channels and
through that the result in 11 weeks was
470 bone marrow drive run nearly 25,000
South Asians registered and in that time
Samir found a perfect match and then
they found a good match Samir now shared
his to his story even though he was sort
of private about this all because he
wanted to raise venture money and he
didn't want this out and he wanted it to
be you know private but once 25 thousand
people acted for him he wanted to open
up he started
blogging shared that story and he
started appreciating life in a very
meaningful way not in a happy excited
way but in a deeply meaningful way in a
way that talked a lot about significance
a lot about savoring a lot about others
and appreciation and it wasn't winning
winning winning it was hard it was
winning and losing and being scared and
and wanting something and feeling
grateful for what others had done he
even put his bone marrow registry onto
YouTube so that in future years people
could see that actually giving and
receiving bone marrow is not nearly as
difficult as you think and the lessons
they learned was the power of a single
focused goal 20,000 South Asians in
their registry the power of reversing
the rules doing things in very
unexpected ways and grabbing attention
and how do you tell a good and truthful
story because otherwise people simply
won't act and then how do you design for
the network allowing everyone to in fact
contribute and choose their own weapon
Samir tho relapsed within three months
of his transplant at the end of my class
and that was him two days before with
Rina they celebrated his life by sharing
a memorial service in the world so a
global live webcast with 6000 people
participating Vinay also had a
successful transplant but he also
relapsed a few months after Samir and he
passed on in June but the purpose
revealed as 40 percent of you here know
is that 266 people were matched in one
year alone and that is 266 people that
don't have just the gift of hope at the
gift of time because the odds of
survival go up from 40 to 80% if you
find a perfect match immediately and the
final thoughts was that most revolutions
are sparked by the actions of a few and
your biggest asset is a clear mind and a
large idea to find that ignition point
and light it and as I was listening to
Robert's story Robert just like you my
students sitting in a seat just like
yours sharing a story that just made me
sob all I could think about is what
would I do now could i water this story
with the story grow how would that make
me feel and all I could think about was
that would make me happy so I talked to
Andi that night and I said what could we
do to help you know I admitted that
social media had some redeeming feature
and we started interviewing people
people that harness social networks
harness story to significant effect and
we found that all of them did these four
things all of them had a single focus
goal not two not three but a single one
they all grabbed attention and reverse
the rules did things in very unexpected
ways they all engaged and we're anchored
on audience creating authentic relevant
content and they all enabled action this
idea of design for the network versus an
an individual defined all of their
movements so that story well told
created 470 bone marrow drives all
across the United States and then it led
us to you know basically write this book
the Dragonfly effect which I didn't ever
want to write but it just kind of I feel
like Samir was writing it for us and
then it allowed us to work with a
hundred thousand sheiks these twelve
students here at Stanford who in honor
and legacy of Samir and Vinay got over a
hundred thirteen thousand people in the
bone marrow registry in one year alone
harnessing social networks and story and
that led to open IDEO participating and
co-creating a design challenge to
electrify an ignite over a million
people internationally which led to at
least one match of a meet Gupta with his
friends and family and network who is
alive and healthy today when diagnosed
with leukemia found a match and that
makes me happy
and it makes me happy in a way that's
very very anxious and gratefulness and
blessedness and I think all of us have
closeted careers and all of us like
maybe being an oncologist and and this
opportunity for you to be back here at
your reunion
in in the space of potentially thinking
of that six word story that defined your
time here and then thinking about your
next chapter what do you want that six
word story to be and to what degree do
you want to have a very different
definition of happiness to what degree
do you want to search or chase different
things and might be create legacy for
you so what to do on Monday three things
I hope you continue to think of story as
an asset for your company and design
with authenticity empathy and purpose I
hope you continue to think of story as
life with our three kids we now ask over
the dinner table what was the story of
the day because it turns out when you
ask them what you do do today you get
nothing but when you ask them to share
just one story and it could be funny
it could be sad it could be anything
they will lead to conversations that are
much richer and your relationship will
be much richer at least it was with ours
stories clarify our past and they can
guide our future stories create and
capture meaning so Bank your stories
just like you did with me in 30 seconds
and you'll find that the most important
stories that define your past and will
indicate your future are those that are
indeed personal distinct relevant
memorable they depicts something larger
they create legacy so in conclusion tell
me the facts and I'll learn tell me the
truth and I'll believe but tell me a
story and it will live in my heart
forever thank you
you